as enterprises move their applications
and services to the cloud
developers need to evaluate and
experiment with new technologies and
tools to figure out what works best for
them
this evaluation process includes tasks
like identifying which cloud providers
to use
trying out new products and learning how
to use new apis
however we know from talking with
developers that this initial evaluation
and setup phase often takes longer than
expected
maybe you run into problems while
getting your development environment set
up like finding the right libraries and
dependencies
you probably don't want to spend hours
trying to install all the right tools or
trying to figure out why the code works
on your friend's machine
but not yours even after setup
switching back and forth between
documentation your ide
your terminal window and your cloud
console can get messy
this is where cloud shell editor comes
into play
cloud shell provides you with command
line access to your cloud resources
directly from your web browser
in cloud shell editor available at
ide.cloud.google.com
extends cloud shell with an online
development environment
powered by the eclipse thea ide platform
cloud shell editor
makes it easy for you to write code
directly from your web browser and
deploy it to the cloud
this online development environment
comes packed with powerful features to
streamline your development workflows
first cloud shell editor integrates
cloud code a set of id plug-ins that
help you stay productive when developing
cloud-native applications
cloud code simplifies kubernetes and
cloud-run development workflows
it allows you to build deploy and debug
your application in just a couple clicks
it also comes packaged with container
tools like mini cubes scaffold
build packs and jib and with its api
explorer
discovering enabling and adding cloud
apis your application is easy
cloud shell editor also has version
control and support for multiple
projects
making it easy for you to collaborate
with teammates
cloud channel editor also has rich
language support for many popular
programming languages
to make it easy for you to write
functional clean and beautiful code
to help you get started we have online
interactive tutorials to get you up to
speed
you can try some of our cloud shell
editor quick starts for google
kubernetes engine
and cloud run with cloud shell editor we
want to make it easy for you to explore
new cloud technologies prototype
applications and do development tasks
directly from your web browser
check it out at ide.cloud.google.com let
us know what you think and stay tuned
for more episodes
[Music]
you